well happy february we're starting off
our first morning of the new month with
clouds out there starting to see just a
little bit of some blue and we'll start
to feel some northerly breezes as we get
into the afternoon hours and by then we
should see a lot more sunshine too these
clouds i'll show you on the satellite
are already easing their way on down the
road lots of 40s around the valley this
morning because the overnight clouds
annelis has a slight northeast breeze
which pushed you back up to 50 degrees
31 at kyle canyon your headlines read
like this clouds that will give way to
sunshine through the day will get back
up near 60 degrees for highs which is
perfectly normal to start off february
gusty north winds start developing
breezy to gusty overnight tonight
especially into tomorrow and it's all
behind a cold front which will move
through today but then the winds really
develop behind the front by tomorrow and
then slowly we'll warm back to 60s
because we're going to drop more than 10
degrees for daytime highs tomorrow and
morning temperatures are going to be
really chilly by thursday see all these
areas of blue and white winter storm
watches and warnings as the storm
gathers in the middle of the country by
tonight and through thursday these
watches and warnings reach from new
mexico to new england boy it's going to
be another big storm to watch for the
rest of the week here's our cold front
right here and it is helping to kind of
push out the cloud cover that we've had
gathering in the desert southwest since
yesterday see this light green and white
that's really upper level moisture in
the clouds we haven't had any showers
from it we've stayed very dry dew points
are in the teens this morning and that
just tells us there's very little
moisture in the air let's talk wind wind
is going to be the biggest element of
this system again we've got wind
advisories issued for areas of southern
nevada southern clark county and those
are mainly for the lakes lake smead
mojave and along the river
colorado river valley
also include areas like searchlight cal
nevery and down to prim and along i-15
into southeast california that's
tomorrow 10 a.m to 7 p.m
where gusts could exceed 50 miles an
hour it's going to lift up blowing dust
it's going to be hazardous for high
profile vehicles 61 is what we're
reaching for today we'll see we'll have
a lot more sun to work with in the
afternoon than we did yesterday and then
tonight we get breezy to downright windy
and especially through groundhog day
tomorrow wednesday plus temperatures are
going to drop behind that cold front so
we're going to have a a drop in temps
plus a wind chill factor to deal with
tomorrow 30 to 40 mile per hour winds
just for the valley well it's going to
be windy so secure loose items around
your yard take the time to do that turn
off your sprinklers for wednesday and
then we're down to freezing in many
neighborhoods by thursday morning even
20's in outlying areas 50's slowly we
get back to 60's for the weekend